une gerbe de fleurs offertes par un
jeune joueur de sochaux à alain giresse
le symbole de l'hommage pour tout un
public à l'occasion du 500e match de
championnat du bordelais quinze ans de
carrière 150 but marqué à 33 ans le
vétéran giresse le corps plutôt bien je
suis trésor des champions et championnes
du monde et connor se porte pas très
bien puisqu'on est de la même année
mais côté c'est je trouve aussi
l'expérience qui est ça qui au fil des
années et quelque chose d'irremplaçable
on a beaucoup de qualités quand on est
jeune sur toute l'élite et athlétique
physique mais je crois que l'expérience
lui permet de maîtriser tout ça lorsque
l'on perd d'un côté alors à trèbes de
l'autre je crois que ça fait un bon
équilibre
et si en plus on vit une vie correcte je
crois que cinq ans c'est pas très vieux
pour sportifs de haut niveau
hier à sochaux le capitaine bordelais à
la tête d'une formation très rajeunie et
amoindri par l'absence de cinq
titulaires a donné l'exemple distribuant
bien le jeu en milieu de terrain et se
montrant très incisifs en attaque 90
minutes ordinaire pour gym est le fidèle
qui n'a connu que le maillot des
girondins
et ça ça match j'aurais pu les faire sur
différents maillots non mais c'est avec
le même maillot celui de jardin et
l'achète sache une certaine importance
parce que je peux considérer les jardins
qui on va souvent de familles je n'ai
connu que ce que le même depuis mai mais
des plus dans les équipes de jeunes
ça fait maintenant 25 ans que surgit
rooney et ses 16 matches sous le maillot
c'est vrai on représente quelque chose
mais secret d'une telle longévité
beaucoup de sérieux dans la préparation
mais aussi beaucoup de patience
giresse a dû en effet attendre 1983 pour
remporter son premier titre de champion
de france
peut-être j'aurais eu envie de partir
bon et j'avais la possibilité surtout
bordeaux proposer de grandes choses
c'est à dire la possibilité d'être
champion de de côtoyer le haut niveau et
à partir 500 matches cela représente 750
heures passées sur un terrain des
chiffres qui n'impressionne pourtant pas
alain giresse
si vous voulez j'ai pas l'impression
d'avoir fait ça marche ça marche ça
représente quelque chose d'énorme mais
moi j'ai pas l'impression ça ce chiffre
me dit rien j'ai toujours envie de jouer
toujours envie de m'amuser sur un
terrain donc je pense que c'est un bon
signe un bon signe en effet pour
bordeaux qui aura bien besoin de lui
pour tenter de combler son handicap dans
le championnat et surtout pour l'équipe
de france dans la perspective de la
coupe du monde l'année prochaine au
mexique